Narrator:
TONIGHT, SILICON VALLEY
BILLIONAIRE CHRIS SACCA
JOINS THE SHARKS.
IDEAS ARE CHEAP.
EXECUTION IS EVERYTHING.
Narrator:
IN THE TANK, ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
GETTING INTO COLLEGE
IS A BIG DEAL.
HOW TO PAY FOR IT...
IS AN ORDEAL.
FIX IS THE APP THAT FIGHTS BACK.
Narrator:
IF THE SHARKS HEAR A GREAT IDEA,
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY YET?
WE HAVE NOT SOLD ANY.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I LOVE THE IDEA.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, MARK?
YES OR NO?
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
I APOLOGIZE FOR MAKING IT
CONFUSING,
BUT WE DO HAVE A PLAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT MIKE TYSON SAID,
RIGHT?
EVERYBODY HAS A PLAN UNTIL
THEY GET PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
the PROBLEM FOR ME IS YOU'RE
ASKING FOR $700,000 FOR 5%.
BEFORE YOU GO OUT,
COULD YOU MAKE US AN OFFER?
-BOO-YAH.
-I DON'T KNOW.
-COME ON.
-LORI! LORI! LORI! LORI!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND BILLIONAIRE INVESTOR
CHRIS SACCA
LEFT HIS HIGH-PROFILE POSITION
AT GOOGLE
AT THE HEIGHT OF HIS CAREER
TO START HIS OWN
VENTURE-CAPITAL FUND,
WHICH IS NOW
ONE OF THE HIGHEST PERFORMING
INVESTMENT FUNDS IN HISTORY
WITH EARLY INVESTMENTS
IN TWITTER, INSTAGRAM, AND UBER.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A TECH SOLUTION
TO THE DREADED PARKING TICKET.
♪♪
MY NAME IS DAVID HEGARTY,
AND I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA.
MY COMPANY IS FIXED,
AND WE ARE SEEKING A $700,000
INVESTMENT FOR 5% EQUITY STAKE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LAST TIME
THAT YOU GUYS GOT
A PARKING TICKET.
WHAT WAS THAT ONE EMOTION
YOU FELT
MORE THAN ALL
THE OTHER EMOTIONS?
ANGER, RIGHT?
WHAT IS IT
ABOUT A PARKING TICKET
THAT GENERATES SUCH ANGER IN US?
IT'S THE INJUSTICE
OF THE SITUATION.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY MAKE THESE
SIGNS CONFUSING ON PURPOSE.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY SIT
BY THE METER
WAITING FOR IT TO EXPIRE.
YOU KNOW THAT THE MAN
HAS JUST SCREWED YOU OVER...
[ LAUGHS ]
...AND THERE IS NOTHING
THAT YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT.
O'Leary: UNTIL NOW.
UNTIL NOW.
FIXED IS THE APP
THAT FIGHTS BACK.
SO, HOW DOES IT WORK?
STEP ONE -- TAKE A PHOTOGRAPH
OF YOUR PARKING TICKET.
STEP TWO -- THAT'S IT.
THERE IS NO STEP TWO.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
WE TAKE THAT PARKING TICKET,
WE RUN IT THROUGH
OUR PROPRIETARY ALGORITHM
TO LOOK FOR ISSUES AND ERRORS
THAT MAKE THAT TICKET INVALID.
WHEN WE FIND AN ISSUE,
WE ASSEMBLE A CONTEST LETTER
ON YOUR BEHALF
AND SEND IT TO THE CITY.
FOUR WEEKS LATER, YOU FIND OUT
THAT YOUR TICKET
HAS BEEN DEALT WITH.
WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO EXPAND TO AS MANY CITIES
AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
BECAUSE EVERY CITY NEEDS
A TICKET HERO.
-OH. [ LAUGHS ]
-[ LAUGHS ]
SO, TELL US
THE BUSINESS MODEL.
CERTAINLY.
IT'S A FREE APP DOWNLOAD.
YOU SUBMIT YOUR TICKET.
IF WE BEAT YOUR TICKET,
WE CHARGE A 35% SUCCESS FEE.
WHAT'S THE SUCCESS RATE?
WE WIN ABOUT 20% TO 30%
OF OUR CONTESTS.
SO, HOW MANY PEOPLE
JUST DO IT THEMSELVES?
SO, IN SAN FRANCISCO,
ONLY 5% OF PARKING TICKETS
ARE CONTESTED,
AND THOSE THAT ARE CONTESTED,
I THINK THE WIN RATE
IS ABOUT 20%.
WHAT IS THE TYPICAL REASON
THAT A TICKET WOULD BE --
DISMISSED?
DISMISSED, YEAH.
THERE'S LOTS
OF DIFFERENT REASONS.
SO, INITIALLY,
WE LOOK FOR ERRORS.
SO, THE STATUTORY INFORMATION
THAT THE OFFICER
HAS TO WRITE DOWN.
FREQUENTLY, THEY'RE IN A RUSH,
THEY DON'T WRITE
THAT INFORMATION,
THEY MADE A TYPO
ON THE LICENSE PLATE,
THEY WROTE ACURA
WHEN IT'S AN AUDI.
WE LOOK FOR ALL THESE ISSUES
THAT MAKE THE TICKET INVALID.
OKAY, BUT YOU'RE NOT REALLY
SELLING A HIGHER SUCCESS RATE.
YOU'RE REALLY SELLING THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE CONTESTING.
'CAUSE ONLY 5% OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY CONTEST.
WE'RE ACTUALLY SELLING BOTH.
SO, FIRSTLY IT'S TIME CONSUMING.
ADDITIONALLY,
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT THEIR TICKET IS INVALID
FOR, LIKE, X, Y, AND Z,
SO WE'RE BASICALLY WINNING
THOSE TICKETS THEY WOULD NEVER
HAVE CONTESTED.
BUT DAVID, HOW MANY TICKETS
ARE ISSUED PER YEAR IN AMERICA?
WE ESTIMATE 100 MILLION TICKETS
WRITTEN A YEAR.
SO, THIS IS A MAJOR SOURCE
OF INCOME FOR THE POLICE.
OH, A HUGE SOURCE.
WHAT'S THE AVERAGE PENALTY,
OR TICKET?
IN SAN FRANCISCO,
THE AVERAGE TICKET IS ABOUT $70.
ARE YOU OPERATING
ANYWHERE ELSE RIGHT NOW?
YEAH, WE ARE IN SAN FRANCISCO,
OAKLAND, LOS ANGELES,
AND NEW YORK.
ALL RIGHT,
TELL US ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE A $14 MILLION VALUE
ON THE BUSINESS.
YEAH.
IT MUST BE HUGE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
THIS YEAR ALONE,
I THINK WE'VE DONE $80,000
IN -- IN NET -- NET REVENUE.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO CONTEST A TICKET?
BETWEEN THE CROWD WORKERS,
THE SOFTWARE,
PEOPLE YOU'VE GOT WORKING AT
YOUR PLACE, WHAT DOES IT COST?
FROM AN AVERAGE TICKET,
WE MAKE ABOUT 5 TO 6 BUCKS
IN REVENUE.
YOU ONLY MAKE $5 OR $6
PER SUCCESS?
THAT'S A COMBINATION
OF OUR 35% WIN RATE
WHEN WE BEAT THE TICKET,
AND IF WE HAVE TO PAY
THE TICKET FOR YOU,
WE CHARGE YOU
A $1.95 CONVENIENCE FEE.
WHAT'S IT COST TO ACQUIRE
THE INCREMENTAL CUSTOMER?
WE ACQUIRE USERS
FOR A BLENDED AVERAGE
OF ABOUT 4 TO 5 BUCKS.
-THAT'S NOT EXCITING.
-IS THAT PAID MARKETING?
I MEAN, IS THAT FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER ADS?
UH, NO.
WE HAVE A TEAM OF PEOPLE
THAT FOLLOW THE STREET-CLEANING
VEHICLES IN THE CITY...
[ LAUGHS ]
COME ON.
...AND PUT A FLYER ON THE CARS
THAT HAVE A PARKING TICKET.
OOH.
IT'S ACTUALLY SMART.
IT'S JUST EXPENSIVE.
IT'S NOT THAT EXPENSIVE.
YOU MAKE $5 AVERAGE
ON PROFIT.
IT COSTS YOU $5
TO ACQUIRE THE CUSTOMER.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A DEAL
MARK CUBAN SHOULD PUT
SOME MONEY INTO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE -- NO, NO.
SO, ONCE WE HAVE THE USER,
WE HAVE A 70% RETENTION RATE.
SO, OUR -- OUR USERS --
THE ONLY WAY YOU GROW IT
IS THAT THEY ABUSE THE LAW
MORE AND MORE.
THEY CONSTANTLY GET
MORE PARKING TICKETS.
NO,
IT'S THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
-NO.
-THEY GET ABUSED BY THE LAW.
ON -- ON AVERAGE, OUR USERS GET
ABOUT SIX PARKING TICKETS
A YEAR.
Sacca: I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
THE COST SIDE OF THIS BUSINESS.
I JUST DON'T THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE
ENOUGH PEOPLE TO USE IT,
ULTIMATELY.
BUT DAVID --
SO, I THINK IT'S HARD
FOR YOU TO FIND THE USERS,
AND FRANKLY, YOU KNOW,
I'M AN INVESTOR IN UBER.
YEAH.
AND UBER HAS SHOWN
THAT CAR OWNERSHIP
IS GOING AWAY.
OKAY, SO -- OKAY.
SO YOU'VE GOT A SHRINKING MARKET
YOU'RE ADDRESSING.
BUT LET ME PAINT THIS VISION
FOR YOU, RIGHT?
PARKING TICKETS ALONE
IS ABOUT A $500 MILLION
OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
SPEEDING TICKETS
AND MOVING VIOLATIONS,
THAT'S ANOTHER $3 BILLION TO
$4 BILLION OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
SO, YOU'RE GOING
TO GET PEOPLE
OFF OF SPEEDING TICKETS,
AS WELL?
CORRECT.
FOR MOST PEOPLE,
IT'S THE SAME THING.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
AND ERRORS IN THE TICKET
THAT THEY'RE UNAWARE OF.
WE WANT TO HELP USERS
BASICALLY HANDLE
THEIR MOVING VIOLATIONS
MORE EFFICIENTLY.
THERE'S $100 BILLION SPENT
EACH YEAR IN THE U.S.
BY CONSUMERS
ON LEGAL SERVICES.
SO, WE HAVE ACQUIRED
40,000 USERS OVER A YEAR.
THEY ALREADY SENT US
THEIR TRAFFIC TICKETS.
THEY'RE LIKE, "I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THIS."
YOUR BUSINESS
IS BRINGING IN CUSTOMERS...
EXACTLY. EXACTLY.
...THAT YOU CAN SCALE UP
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME.
WE ARE --
BUT I GET IT,
AND IT'S CLEVER.
YEAH.
HOW IS THAT WORTH
$14 MILLION TODAY?
OKAY, SO I'LL --
I'LL BREAK IT DOWN.
IF WE CONTINUE THE GROWTH
WE HAVE WITH PARKING TICKETS
TO THE END OF THIS YEAR,
WE'LL BE AT AN $11 MILLION
REVENUE RUN RATE.
YOU'RE GONNA GO FROM $80,000 NOW
TO $11 MILLION NEXT YEAR?
AT A RUN RATE
BY THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
SINCE JANUARY THIS YEAR,
WE'VE BEEN GROWING
AT 33% MONTH OVER MONTH.
IF MY 3 YEAR OLD
CONTINUES TO GROW
AT THE SAME RATE
SHE'S GROWING NOW,
SHE'S GONNA BE AN EIGHT-FOOTER
WITHIN A FEW YEARS
AND SHE'LL BE PLAYING
IN THE WNBA.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE HAVEN'T GONE INTO TRAFFIC
AND OTHER MOVING VIOLATIONS YET.
HOW MUCH MONEY
HAVE YOU RAISED?
WE'VE RAISED $1.8 MILLION
IN TOTAL.
-AT WHAT VALUE?
-THAT'S NOT BAD.
THE LAST ROUND
WAS AT A $10 MILLION CAP.
WOW!
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION,
DAVID, PHILOSOPHICALLY.
YOUR BASIC PREMISE IS
YOU BUILD OUT TO OTHER SERVICES,
YOU'RE GONNA SHRINK
GOVERNMENT REVENUES.
THAT'S BASICALLY IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE CHANCES ARE
YOU'RE GONNA GET AUDITED
A LOT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
UH, LISTEN,
I'M NOT BUYING THE SCALE
FROM $80,000 TO $11 MILLION
RUN RATE NEXT YEAR.
I'M OUT.
HERE'S MY PROBLEM WITH IT,
OKAY?
I'M IN THE MUTUAL FUND
BUSINESS.
I'M THE MOST REGULATED GUY
IN THE WORLD.
THE GOVERNMENT LOOKS
AT MY BUSINESS EVERY DAY.
THEY LET ME MAKE MONEY
BECAUSE I STAY COMPLIANT.
YEAH.
I DON'T THINK
I WANT TO INVEST IN A BUSINESS
THAT GOES TO WAR
WITH GOVERNMENT REVENUE.
I JUST THINK
IT'S BAD KARMA FOR ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THE PROBLEM FOR ME IS
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $700,000
FOR A 5% EQUITY STAKE.
[ Sarcastically ]
IT'S A STEAL.
I THINK YOU'RE, LIKE,
JUST CLIMBING
THE MOUNTAIN OF THIS.
MM-HMM.
IT'S A GOOD IDEA,
BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE THERE YET,
AND I CAN'T WRAP MY HANDS AROUND
IF IT'S GONNA REALLY
WORK OR NOT.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
♪♪
LOOK, I KNOW THE SIZE
OF THE MARKET
OF TRAFFIC TICKET AND
AMBULANCE-CHASING LAWYERS...
YEAH.
HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY SPEND...
YEAH.
...TO ACQUIRE CUSTOMERS.
IT'S A HUGE MARKET,
AND I DON'T THINK
ANYONE'S NAILED IT
IN THE APP BUSINESS YET.
BUT FOR ME,
PLACING A BET ON THIS BUSINESS
IS PLACING A BET
AGAINST UBER.
I THINK CAR OWNERSHIP
GOES AWAY,
AND I THINK PRETTY SOON WE'RE
GONNA HAVE AUTOMATED DRIVERS,
WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ROBOTIC CARS GOING AROUND,
AND THAT'S WHERE
I WANT TO BE,
IS INVESTING IN THE FUTURE,
NOT IN THE PRESENT.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I-I DON'T AGREE WITH CHRIS
THAT, YOU KNOW,
CAR OWNERSHIP IS GOING AWAY.
YEAH, I DON'T BUY THAT.
WELL, THE GUYS IN THE FERRARIS
DON'T BUY IT.
NO, I DON'T HAVE A FERRARI.
I'M NOT A CAR GUY.
LOOK, I LOVE THE IDEA OF KICKING
THE GOVERNMENT UP THE ASS.
OH,
THAT'S SUCH A BAD IDEA.
RIGHT?
THERE'S NOTHING
I LIKE MORE.
WE'RE IN THE SAME BOAT.
THERE'S NOTHING I LIKE --
SO, WAIT, BUT THIS IS THE MONEY
THAT ACTUALLY BUILDS THE ROADS,
FUNDS THE LIBRARIES,
BUILDS THE HOMELESS SHELTERS.
OH, WAIT. SO THIS IS --
SO YOU WANT TO BE ON THAT SIDE
OF THE EQUATION?
THIS IS FROM THE PERSON
THAT SAYS, "YOU KNOW WHAT,
NO MORE CARS," WHICH MEANS
NO MORE TAX MONEY FROM THAT,
NO MORE SALES --
THE TAX --
YOU'RE CONSIDERING THIS A TAX.
THIS IS THE MOST REGRESSIVE TAX
THAT IS OUT THERE.
I COMPLETELY AGREE.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
PARKING TICKETS
ARE NOT THE PEOPLE WITH FERRARIS
YOU CAN PUT IN A GARAGE,
BUT PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE A GARAGE,
WHO NEED THEIR CAR
FOR THEIR JOB.
AMEN.
IT IS THE MOST
REGRESSIVE TAX.
AMEN.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, MARK?
YES OR NO?
-UM...
-ON OR OFF, UP OR DOWN?
♪♪
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
MARK CUBAN IS DAVID'S LAST
CHANCE TO GET A DEAL FOR FIXED,
AN APP THAT FIGHTS
PARKING TICKETS.
SO, THE CONCEPT
OF US STANDING OUT THERE
AND SAYING, "YOU KNOW WHAT,
THE GOVERNMENT
HAS COME AFTER YOU
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD
A GARAGE, BECAUSE" --
I LOVE THAT IDEA.
YEAH, IT'S GREAT.
I THINK OPERATIONALLY,
THERE'S SOME CHALLENGES
IN ORDER TO SCALE
FAR MORE QUICKLY THAT
I CAN HELP YOU WITH.
SO, WHAT I'LL OFFER YOU
IS YOUR $700,000...
FOR 7%, RIGHT?
AND WE CAN STRUCTURE
THAT EXTRA 2%
AS ADVISORY FEES,
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
THAT --
THAT MAKES IT A FLAT ROUND,
WHICH IS NOT GREAT
FOR OUR EXISTING INVESTORS.
NOT IF IT'S 2%
FOR ADVISORY FEES.
IT'S NOT A FLAT ROUND.
THAT MEANS YOU PUT NO VALUE
ON A SHARK.
WELL, WE'VE PROGRESSED A TON
SINCE WE -- OUR LAST --
THAT'S FINE.
OKAY, SO --
AND YOU'RE GONNA PROGRESS
EVEN MORE WHEN I GET INVOLVED.
I-I GET THAT.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I HAVE YOU ON --
LIKE, 2% IS A LOT, A LOT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S TIME --
YOU CAN E-MAIL ME ANYTIME
NIGHT OR DAY,
AND YOU'RE GONNA GET
A RETURN E-MAIL FROM ME
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
MAKE A DECISION.
'CAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE GETTING
A PARKING TICKET OUTSIDE
RIGHT NOW.
♪♪
I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I HAVE YOUR WORD
THAT WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
A FULL COMMITMENT FROM YOU
AND YOU'RE AVAILABLE WHEN
WE NEED YOU TO HELP US OUT.
SURE.
WE HAVE A DEAL.
DONE.
Greiner: [ CHUCKLES ]
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-IT'LL BE WORTH IT, TRUST ME.
-I'M PSYCHED ABOUT THIS.
GOOD LUCK.
SEE YOU AT THE AUDIT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU JUST PAID $700,000
FOR A COMPANY
DOING $80,000 IN REVENUE.
I PAID $300,000
FOR A COMPANY WITH NO REVENUE.
IT WAS CALLED UBER.
INTERESTING.
Hegarty:
WE HAVE A BIG VISION.
NOW THAT MARK
IS PART OF THAT VISION,
IT REALLY IS
THE SKY'S THE LIMIT.
HE'S A CONTRARIAN THINKER,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED
ON THE TEAM.
Narrator: IN SEASON FIVE,
ROB DICKENS AND BRAD SCUDDER
STRUCK A DEAL WITH MARK CUBAN
FOR THEIR EVENTS COMPANY
RUGGED RACES.
WE'D LIKE TO STRIKE A DEAL
WITH YOU.
-$1.75 MILLION FOR THE 25%.
-DEAL.
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
[ AIR HORN BLOWS ]
WE'VE BEEN WORKING
LIKE MANIACS
SINCE WE MADE OUR DEAL
ON "SHARK TANK."
MARK CUBAN INVESTED
$1.75 MILLION IN OUR COMPANY,
AND THAT'S ALLOWED US
TO REALLY ACCELERATE OUR GROWTH.
WE'VE EXPANDED TO 28 CITIES,
AND OUR ATTENDANCE HAS EXPLODED.
OVER 200,000 PEOPLE HAVE NOW
REGISTERED FOR OUR RACES,
AND WE'RE GETTING AS MANY
AS 18,000 PEOPLE OUT
TO A SINGLE EVENT.
THIS HAS ALL TRANSLATED
INTO HUGE SALES FOR US.
IN THE YEAR BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD $4.2 MILLION.
AFTER "SHARK TANK," WE'VE GOT
$10.5 MILLION IN SALES.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
HERE'S THE COURSE MAP
FOR OUR NEW ENGLAND EVENT
TOMORROW.
WE'VE MOVED TO NEW OFFICES,
WE'VE HIRED 20 NEW PEOPLE.
WE'VE GOT A GREAT SPACE NOW
THAT'S REALLY HELPING OUR
CREATIVITY AND OUR PRODUCTION.
What's up, guys?
HOW YOU DOING, MARK?
SAYING THAT WE ARE PARTNERS
WITH MARK CUBAN OPENS DOORS.
Where are we at with sponsors?
I THINK WE'RE GONNA SEE 30% TO
40% GROWTH GOING INTO NEXT YEAR.
VENUES NOW WANT
TO WORK WITH US,
SPONSORS NOW WANT
TO WORK WITH US.
HAVING MARK ON OUR TEAM
REALLY GIVES US A FOOT UP
ON EVERYBODY ELSE.
Keep in touch,
and congratulations, guys.
HEY, THANKS, MARK.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANKS A LOT.
GOOD JOB, GUYS.
GOOD JOB.
WE HAVE A LOT OF BIG THINGS
PLANNED FOR THE FUTURE.
WE'VE ALREADY EXPANDED
INTO CANADA.
WE HAVE A NEW EVENT SERIES
CALLED COSTUME DASH 5K,
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
EVENT PRODUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES, AS WELL.
WHEN PEOPLE THINK
OF OBSTACLE COURSE RACING,
WE WANT THEM TO THINK
RUGGED MANIAC.
WE WANT TO BE THE PINNACLE
OF THE SPORT.
MANIAC!
[ ALL CHEERING ]
♪♪
I'M ANN.
AND I'M DAVE.
AND WE LIVE
IN PALO ALTO, CALIFORNIA,
WITH OUR KIDS MAYA,
DEREK, AND BEN.
OUR KIDS ARE ABSOLUTELY
THE CENTER OF OUR WORLD.
BECOMING A PARENT IS AMAZING,
BUT IS ALSO SCARY.
SO CLOSE.
YAY!
WHEN MY DAUGHTER MAYA WAS BORN,
I TRIED TO BREASTFEED HER,
BUT I REALIZED THAT
SHE WAS LOSING TOO MUCH WEIGHT.
I WAS REALLY ANXIOUS,
AND I TOOK HER
TO THE DOCTOR REGULARLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE WAS
GROWING AND THAT SHE WAS OKAY.
WE KNOW HOW SCARY IT IS
TO BRING A BABY HOME
FROM THE HOSPITAL
AND TO NOT KNOW
HOW SHE'S DEVELOPING.
WE WANT TO HELP EASE
SOME OF THOSE WORRIES
THAT EVERY NEW PARENT HAS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF KNOWLEDGE
IN THE BABY INDUSTRY,
BUT WE'VE NEVER SOLD
A PHYSICAL PRODUCT BEFORE.
WE WANT THE SHARKS BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN THE POWER
OF WHAT THEY CAN DO
FOR BUSINESSES,
AND WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY THRILLED
TO GET THE CHANCE
TO PITCH TO THEM.
♪♪
HI.
MY NAME IS ANN CRADY-WEISS.
AND I'M HER HUSBAND
DAVE WEISS.
AND TOGETHER, WE'RE
THE CO-FOUNDERS OF HATCH BABY.
WE ARE SEEKING $250,000
FOR 2.5% OF OUR COMPANY.
BECOMING A NEW PARENT
IS FULL OF WONDER.
AND WORRY.
IT IS SCARY TO BRING A NEW
INFANT HOME FROM THE HOSPITAL
AND TO BLINDLY TRUST THAT
SHE'S DEVELOPING AS SHE SHOULD.
THE BIGGEST PREDICTOR
OF INFANT HEALTH
IN THE EARLY DAYS
IS WEIGHT GAIN.
BABIES ARE CHECKED
AT DOCTOR'S VISITS,
BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL THE TIME
IN BETWEEN THOSE VISITS?
WE'RE HERE
TO PUT PARENT'S MINDS AT EASE.
WE DEVELOPED
THE SMART CHANGING PAD.
IT'S A MODERN RE-DESIGN
OF THE TRADITIONAL
DIAPER-CHANGING PAD
FOUND
IN EVERY BABY NURSERY.
IT HAS A BUILT-IN
WI-FI ENABLED SCALE
SO THAT YOU CAN SEE
HOW MUCH YOUR BABY WEIGHS
AND TELL HOW MUCH YOU'RE NURSING
DURING A FEEDING.
ALL OF THE INFORMATION SYNCS
TO YOUR SMARTPHONE.
NO MATTER WHO IS TAKING CARE
OF YOUR BABY,
YOU CAN CHECK IN ANYTIME,
ANYWHERE,
AND BE READY TO SHARE
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT YOU AND
YOUR PEDIATRICIAN CARE ABOUT,
AND THAT LEAVES MORE TIME
FOR THE GOOD STUFF.
SHARKS, PLEASE JOIN US
IN HELPING BABIES STAY ON TRACK
AND PARENTS STAY SANE.
WE WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS.
INTERESTING,
BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT PRODUCT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME WITHOUT
ANY FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE,
BUT DO I REALLY NEED TO KNOW
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL EVERY TIME?
WHEN I FIRST BECAME A MOM
12 YEARS AGO, I PREPARED A TON.
AND THEN I BROUGHT MY BABY HOME,
AND I WAS TERRIFIED.
I REALLY WANTED
TO BREASTFEED HER,
BUT WHY WAS SHE CRYING?
WAS SHE CRYING BECAUSE
SHE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH?
WAS SHE CRYING
FOR ANOTHER REASON?
WHY WAS SHE CRYING?
AND I KNOW NOW
THAT I'M NOT ALONE.
MORE THAN 90% OF MOMS
HAVE ANXIETY IN THE FIRST WEEKS.
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF MOMS
DON'T MEET THEIR OWN
BREASTFEEDING GOALS
BECAUSE THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR SUPPLY.
HOW DID THE SCALE
HELP YOU WITH THAT?
HOW DOES THIS
TRACK ANY OF THAT?
-YEAH.
-SO, THE WAY IT TRACKS IT
IS BEFORE YOU NURSE,
YOU DO YOUR NORMAL THING,
YOU CHANGE YOUR BABY.
YOU TAP THE FEEDING BUTTON,
RECORDS A WEIGHT.
YOU GO AND YOU NURSE YOUR BABY,
THEN YOU BRING THE BABY BACK,
TOUCH THE SAME BUTTON AGAIN,
PUT THE BABY DOWN,
IT'LL TELL YOU
YOU FED 2.75 OUNCES.
-IT'S THAT SENSITIVE A SCALE?
-IT'S THAT SENSITIVE A SCALE.
THAT'S THE PRIMARY FUNCTION
OF HATCH BABY
IS TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH BREAST
MILK THE CHILD IS CONSUMING?
THE PRIMARY FUNCTION
OF HATCH BABY
IS TO REASSURE PARENTS
THAT THEIR BABIES ARE DEVELOPING
AS THEY SHOULD BE
AND ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT MOMS CAN MEET
THEIR OWN BREASTFEEDING GOALS.
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY YET?
WE HAVE NOT SOLD ANY.
THIS IS IN PREPRODUCTION.
SO, WE LAUNCHED OUR WEBSITE
LAST WEEK.
WE'RE DOING PRE-SALES
IN THE COMING WEEKS.
LAST WEEK?
AND WE WILL HAVE PRODUCT
SHIPPING TO MOMS
IN THE COMING MONTH.
SO, YOU'VE GOT
A $10 MILLION VALUATION
ON THE PRE-REVENUE,
PRE-NOTHING.
AND WE'D LOVE
TO TELL YOU WHY.
OH, WE WANT TO HEAR IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ Laughing ]
I BET YOU DO.
I REALLY WANT
TO HEAR THIS.
WE ARE EXPERIENCED
ENTREPRENEURS AND EXECUTIVES
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
SO, I STARTED A COMPANY
THAT I SOLD
TO JOHNSON & JOHNSON.
JOHNSON & JOHNSON HAS A DIVISION
CALLED BabyCenter.
40 MILLION MOMS WORLDWIDE
USE BabyCenter.
DAVE AND I MET AT BabyCenter,
AND BETWEEN THE TWO OF US,
WE RAN EVERYTHING
CONSUMER-FACING.
WE RAN PRODUCT,
EDITORIAL,
DESIGN, ENGINEERING,
AND MARKETING.
IT IS LITERALLY THE PLACE YOU GO
FOR ANSWERS IN THIS SPACE.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TWO YOUNG GIRLS
AND ONE MORE ON THE WAY,
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU GO.
YOU'RE FREAKED OUT,
YOU NEED AN ANSWER.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT THIS FEVER,
THAT COLOR POOP,
YOU'RE GOING TO BabyCenter.
-YEAH.
-SO, YOU'VE GOT
GREAT EXPERIENCE.
SOLD ME ON THAT.
CHECK.
SO, TO GO ON
ABOUT THE VALUATION,
THE WAY WE GOT TO IT IS WE WENT
BACK TO THE SAME INVESTORS
WHO FUNDED MY LAST COMPANY.
WE RAISED $1.7 MILLION
ON A CONVERTIBLE NOTE
LAST SEPTEMBER
WHEN THIS WAS ESSENTIALLY
CONCEPT PHASE.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK
IT HAS LEGS?
WELL, OUR EXPERIENCE
FROM BabyCenter TELLS US
THAT THIS IS A PRODUCT
THAT MOMS WANT.
THERE'S A LOT MORE INFORMATION
YOU WANT TO TRACK
OTHER THAN JUST THINGS
THAT ARE WEIGHT-BASED.
ABSOLUTELY,
AND WE SEE THE FUTURE.
WE SEE THERE ABSOLUTELY
WILL BE A SMART NURSERY AND --
Sacca: ONE OF THE THINGS
I THINK YOU'VE MISSED
IS THAT APART FROM
JUST DEALING WITH THE ANXIETY,
THERE'S JUST THE VANITY
AND THE GEEKY DESIRE
TO AGGREGATE ALL THIS DATA.
-BUT I COULD GET
A SENSITIVE SCALE...
-YOU COULD WEIGH A BABY.
...AND I COULD WEIGH THE CHILD
BEFORE AND AFTER. SURE.
AND THERE'S -- I'M SURE
THERE'S BLUETOOTH-BASED SCALES
THAT CONNECT TO AN APP.
TALK ABOUT THIS PRODUCT.
PRICE TO MAKE IT,
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SELL IT FOR.
SO, TO MAKE IT, IT COSTS $89,
AND WE'LL SELL IT FOR $299.
WOW.
AND THE PRICE IS IN LINE
WITH OTHER PREMIUM
BABY PRODUCTS OUT THERE.
O'Leary:
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
FOR THE AVERAGE FAMILY
THAT MAKES $33,000 A YEAR...
RIGHT.
...CAN I REALLY GET
$250 WORTH OF VALUE
FROM A SCALE?
SOME WANT TO PAY MORE
BECAUSE THIS IS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THEIR BABY.
BUT ALSO, WE CAN LOOK
AT OTHER COMPARABLES
LIKE THE STROLLER MARKET.
YOU LOOK AT, YOU KNOW,
20 YEARS AGO,
STROLLERS WERE A UTILITY.
WE USE THEM
TO PUSH OUR KIDS AROUND.
NOW THEY ARE, YOU KNOW,
$500 IS THE MINIMUM,
AND THEY ARE SELLING
LIKE HOTCAKES.
YOU HAVE SO -- SO MUCH
CREDIBILITY IN THIS SPACE.
YOU KNOW, YOU WOULD BE
A GREAT RECORDING ARTIST.
GETS A HUGE HIT ALBUM,
YOU KNOW?
AND THEN THE NEXT ALBUM,
FIVE TRACKS SUCK.
-YOU JUST DON'T KNOW.
-[ LAUGHS ]
SO -- SO, WE DISAGREE.
I KNOW I --
O'Leary:
OF COURSE WE DISAGREE,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A SCALE --
A $300 SCALE,
THAT IS --
YOU COULD SAY THAT A FITBIT
WAS A $100 PEDOMETER.
THEY'RE ABOUT TO I.P.O.
FOR A BILLION DOLLARS,
AND WE'RE BACKED
BY THE SAME PEOPLE.
THE BABY MARKET
TIME AND TIME AGAIN HAS SHOWN
THAT PRICE IS NOT WHAT PARENTS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
I AGREE.
ANY TIME
IN YOUR ENTIRE LIFE
THAT YOU WILL THROW
YOUR BUDGET OUT THE WINDOW,
IT IS FOR YOUR BABY.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA GET IT
TO MARKET?
AT FIRST, WE'RE EXCLUSIVELY
SELLING ONLINE ON OUR SITE.
AND SO WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SELL IN THE FIRST YEAR?
SO, IN THE FIRST YEAR,
WE FORECAST WE'RE GONNA SELL
20,000 UNITS.
20,000 UNITS?
WHAT'S THE REVENUE OF THAT?
$6 MILLION.
YOU'RE GONNA GO TO 20,000 UNITS
FIRST YEAR?
YES.
WE THINK
IT'S A TINY FRACTION
OF 1% OF THE CHANGING PAD
MARKET.
-WE THINK --
-IT IS, BUT IT'S OPTIMISTIC.
THE CHALLENGE IS
WHETHER YOUR DEVICE WILL WIN
IN THAT COMPETITION
WITH ALL THE OTHER DEVICES.
I'M NOT BUYING THAT IT IS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THERE ARE OTHER PLAYERS
IN THE SMART BABY MARKET,
BUT ABSOLUTELY
SOMEONE WILL WIN,
AND WHO WOULD YOU RATHER
MAKE A BET ON?
YOU KNOW WHAT MIKE TYSON SAID,
RIGHT?
NO.
EVERYBODY HAS A PLAN UNTIL
THEY GET PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
I SEE THE VALUE,
BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S A FEATURE
OF SOME OTHER PRODUCT
OR IT'S ENOUGH
TO CARRY IT ON ITS OWN,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M GOING OUT.
♪♪
PAST SUCCESS IS NOT ALWAYS
AN INDICATOR FOR FUTURE SUCCESS.
SO --
I JUST DON'T BUY
INTO THIS $300 CHANGING TABLE.
I'M OUT.
I'VE BEEN IN THE PRODUCT ARENA
FOR A VERY, VERY LONG TIME.
AND I DO THINK
THAT WHILE PEOPLE MAY LIKE IT
AND THEY MAY WANT TO BUY IT,
NOT EVERYBODY ACROSS AMERICA CAN
AFFORD A $300 CHANGING TABLE.
I'M NOT SURE
IT'S A BIG ENOUGH PROBLEM
WHERE PEOPLE WILL REALLY
STRETCH OUT OF THEIR BUDGETS
THAT FAR TO BUY IT.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
O'Leary:
I DON'T THINK THIS THING
IS GOING TO BE AS SUCCESSFUL
AS YOU SUGGEST
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
AMERICA CAN AFFORD IT.
AND FOR YOUR VALUATION,
YOU HAVE TO PRETTY WELL
HAVE EVERYBODY SAY,
"I HAVE TO HAVE A HATCH BABY."
I THINK
THIS IS YOUR THIRD ALBUM,
AND IT'S NOT SO GOOD.
WE -- WE DO WANT A SHARK ON --
I MEAN, WE WANT A SHARK --
WE DO WANT A SHARK
ON OUR TEAM.
WELL, IT WON'T BE ME
BECAUSE I'M OUT.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
CHRIS SACCA'S LEFT.
AND HE'S THE TARGET MARKET.
HE HAS A CHILD ON THE WAY.
Sacca: I'M LOOKING AT THIS,
AND I LIKE SMART NURSERY,
I LIKE CHANGING TABLE
AS A PLATFORM.
I COMPLETELY IDENTIFY
WITH THAT ANXIETY
IN THE EARLY DAYS
OF BRINGING A KID HOME.
THE ISSUE YOU'RE SOLVING IS
A RELATIVELY SHORT-TERM ISSUE,
AND SO WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS
YOU HAVEN'T BUILT SOMETHING
THAT HAS LONGEVITY,
THAT MAKES THIS THING NECESSARY
AND INDISPENSABLE
TO JUSTIFY THAT KIND
OF TICKET ITEM.
I'D BE VERY INTERESTED
IN THE OTHER THINGS
THAT GO IN THE ROOM --
THE MONITORING,
THE TEMPERATURE TAKING,
THE HEART RATE --
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
IN EARLY BEFORE WE GET THERE.
SO, YEAH. SO, I LOVE TO GET IN
EARLY IN COMPANIES.
I GOT INTO UBER
AT A $3 MILLION VALUATION,
AND THAT'S WHY
AT A $50 BILLION VALUATION,
I'M FEELING
REALLY GOOD ABOUT IT.
BUT WE ALREADY HAD CARS
ON THE ROAD,
THERE WERE USERS ON THE SERVICE.
IT WAS WORKING.
THIS AT THE PROTOTYPE STAGE,
I THINK THIS IS OVER VALUED.
I'M OUT.
I'M SO SORRY TO HEAR THAT,
BUT I DO WANT TO TAKE
ONE MORE SHOT.
WE BELIEVE
IN THIS BUSINESS.
WE PUT OUR HEART AND SOUL
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
WE DO THINK THAT WE'RE WORTH
$10 MILLION,
AND WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN GET THE MONEY,
BUT THE REALITY IS WE KNOW
WHAT YOU GUYS DO FOR COMPANIES.
WE WANT YOU GUYS, AND SO
IF VALUATION IS A CONCERN --
WELL, I --
...WE WOULD LOVE TO FIND
A WAY TO BE CREATIVE.
HERE IS AN IDEA.
WE RAISED MONEY LAST SEPTEMBER.
WE HAVE $250,000 LEFT
ON THAT NOTE.
WE WOULD LOVE TO BRING YOU GUYS
IN ON THAT NOTE.
WE'LL GIVE YOU THE SAME TERMS
AS WE GAVE PEOPLE
WHEN IT WAS CONCEPT PHASE.
THE FIRST MONEY IN.
WHAT WAS THE VALUATION?
WELL,
IT'S ON A CONVERTIBLE NOTE,
SO IT'S A $7.5 MILLION CAP.
WE'RE HERE TO MAKE A DEAL.
WE BELIEVE
THAT WITH YOU GUYS AS PARTNERS,
THIS CAN GET TO EVERY PARENT.
I'LL DO THE 250K UNDER THE TERMS
OF THE CONVERTIBLE NOTE.
♪♪
BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M ON THE SAME TERMS
AS ALL THE OTHER INVESTORS
WHO LEAD THE DEAL AT THE SERIES.
IS THAT A DONE DEAL?
-YES! ABSOLUTELY!
-ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS, CHRIS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE'VE HEARD AMAZING,
AMAZING THINGS ABOUT YOU.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-YEAH. RIGHT ON, MAN.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
-GOOD LUCK.
-THANK YOU.
♪♪
[ LAUGHS ]
Weiss: WE COULDN'T BE HAPPIER.
CHRIS IS A NEW DAD.
WE LOVE
HIS INVESTMENT PROFILE.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT HE CAN DO
TO COMPANIES.
HE'S TWITTER, HE'S UBER,
HE'S -- HE'S AMAZING.
WE'RE SO GLAD
TO HAVE HIM AS A PARTNER.
TOTALLY.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A BUSINESS
THAT HOPES TO EASE
THE PAIN OF PAYING FOR COLLEGE.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ANTONIO ADAMS.
AND I'M TASHA ADAMS.
AND WE'RE TWINS.
FROM DENVER, COLORADO.
Together: OUR COMPANY IS
VILLAGE SCHOLARSHIPS.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
SEEKING $125,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
OF OUR COMPANY.
GETTING ACCEPTED INTO COLLEGE
IS A BIG DEAL.
BUT FIGURING OUT
HOW TO PAY FOR IT...
IS AN ORDEAL.
BUT WHAT IF THERE WAS
A SOLUTION
TO SOLVE FUTURE STUDENT DEBT
THAT WAS BOTH...
VIABLE AND PROFITABLE?
YES.
WELL, THERE IS
WITH VILLAGE SCHOLARSHIPS.
IT'S WHERE MATCHMAKING MEETS
A NEW TYPE OF CROWD FUNDING
THAT FORMS HOMEMADE SCHOLARSHIPS
FUNDED BY...
PEOPLE YOU KNOW...
AND MATCHED BY...
PEOPLE WHO CARE.
ANYONE INTERESTED
IN HELPING COLLEGE STUDENTS
ACHIEVE THEIR COLLEGE DREAM CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO A COLLEGE FUND.
IT'S THAT EASY.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
STUDENTS COME TO OUR WEBSITE,
AND THEY CREATE A PROFILE.
YOU SIMPLY INPUT
YOUR INSTITUTION,
YOUR MAJOR,
AND YOUR TUITION GOAL,
AND YOU SHARE YOUR PROFILE
WITH YOUR SELECT FAMILY
OR FRIENDS
OR YOUR ENTIRE
SOCIAL NETWORK.
AFTER THE COMPLETION
OF A STUDENT'S CAMPAIGNS,
THEIR FUNDS
WILL BE DIRECTLY TRANSFERRED
TO THEIR
UNIVERSITY ACCOUNTS.
SHARKS, HELP US MAKE
A DIFFERENCE...
AND JOIN THE VILLAGE TODAY.
ISN'T IT REALLY
JUST A WAY
FOR FAMILY AND FRIENDS
TO GIVE SOMEBODY MONEY?
WE'RE A TRADITIONAL
CROWD-FUNDING WEBSITE,
BUT WHAT DIFFERENTIATES US IS
THE MATCHING FUND OPPORTUNITY.
SO, THE REASON PEOPLE SOLICIT
FUNDS FROM THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
IS REALLY TO DEVELOP
ENOUGH MONEY
SO THEY CAN MATCH A SCHOLARSHIP
FUND WITH SOMEONE ELSE.
HOW MANY USERS HAVE ACTUALLY
ENTERED THE DATA INTO THIS?
WELL,
CURRENTLY AT THIS TIME,
WE HAVE USERS
THAT ENTERED THEIR DATA,
BUT THE WEBSITE ITSELF
IS NOT COMPLETELY FINISHED,
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE --
-SO THIS IS A CONCEPT.
-YES, WE ARE JUST STARTING.
-SO, YOU'RE JUST STARTING.
IT'S A CONCEPT.
YOU HAVEN'T REALLY GOTTEN --
AH, IT'S A CONCEPT.
THERE WE GO.
AND YOU DON'T --
YOU HAVEN'T MADE ANY MONEY YET.
NO.
ISN'T IT REALLY
JUST A WAY TO DONATE?
YES.
IT'S NOT REALLY A BUSINESS.
WELL, THEY'RE GONNA TAKE A
PERCENTAGE AT SOME POINT, RIGHT?
YES, WE'RE --
IT'S GONNA BE BASED
ON THE TRADITIONAL
SERVICE AND FEES.
WHAT'S YOUR FEE GONNA BE?
THE FEE IS 8.5%
ON THE COMPLETION
OF A STUDENT'S CAMPAIGN.
DANG!
AND THE REASON -- THAT'S
ACTUALLY STANDARD COMMISSION --
-I DON'T THINK SO.
-WOW. NO.
THAT'S THE STANDARD
COMMISSION FEE FOR
TRADITIONAL CROWD FUNDING.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A CROWD-FUNDING SITE,
YOU KNOW, FOR, LIKE,
KICKSTARTER --
I'M AN INVESTOR IN KICKSTARTER.
IT BRINGS DISTRIBUTION
TO YOUR PROJECTS.
SO IF NOBODY'S HEARD
OF YOUR PROJECT BEFORE,
YOU PUT IT THERE,
IT GETS FEATURED.
WHAT HAPPENS HERE,
THOUGH, IS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF YOUR FUNDRAISING
IS COMING FROM PEOPLE YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE THAT ARE
EITHER FRIENDS, FAMILY,
OR MAYBE ONE DEGREE AWAY
FROM YOU.
AND SO THAT FEE THAT YOU'RE
TAKING STARTS TO FEEL HUGE,
AND YOU'RE NOT REALLY BRINGING
ANYTHING TO THE TABLE
THAT THEY DON'T ALREADY HAVE.
WELL, ACTUALLY,
CURRENTLY WITH WEBSITES,
LIKE OUR MAJOR COMPETITOR
WOULD BE, LIKE, A GoFundMe,
THEY'VE, IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS ALONE, HAVE SEEN
A 4,500% INCREASE
IN RAISING --
FUNDRAISING
FOR COLLEGE TUITION ALONE.
BUT CHRIS HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD.
THEY BRING PEOPLE WITH MONEY
TO PEOPLE WITHOUT MONEY.
WHAT IS THE PRIMARY COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS SITE?
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS SITE
IS ACTUALLY
THE MATCHING FUND ASPECT.
YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THE PRIMARY ADVANTAGE IS
THAT STRANGERS WILL MATCH FUNDS.
AM I GETTING THAT RIGHT?
THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF THE WEBSITE IS
WE'LL FIRST START
WITH CROWD FUNDING.
AN INDIVIDUAL
WOULD RECRUIT FRIENDS OR FAMILY
TO THE WEBSITE
TO SOLICIT FUNDS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD BRING
THEMSELVES.
YES.
THAT'S WHERE, ON OUR END,
WE'RE RECRUITING
AND WE'RE BUILDING OUT
A NETWORK OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ALREADY CREATE
SCHOLARSHIPS ON THEIR OWN.
O'Leary:
SO, THIS BECOMES THEIR PLATFORM.
THEY ELECT TO USE
THIS ONE TO GIFT.
YES, AND ALLOWING PEOPLE,
INDIVIDUALS LIKE YOURSELF
OR MYSELF TO SAY,
"I WANT TO CREATE
A $5 SCHOLARSHIP
TO THIS CATEGORY SO THAT ANYONE
THAT MATCHES THESE CRITERIAS
CAN MATCH THEIR FUNDS
WITH ME."
HOW DID YOU GUYS PAY
FOR COLLEGE?
I, DURING UNDERGRAD,
RECEIVED A FULL RIDE
IN OPTICAL ENGINEERING
AT NORFOLK STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND THEN I HAVE A FELLOWSHIP
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA
FOR OPTICAL SCIENCE.
-AND WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
-VERY INTERESTING.
MY BACKGROUND IS
I'VE STARTED
THREE START-UP COMPANIES
IN MY PAST,
BUT ALSO I'M A FORMER
COLLEGE BASKETBALL PLAYER.
AND HOW THE IDEA CAME
TO FRUITION
IS I LOST TWO
ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIPS
DUE TO SEASON-ENDING
INJURIES.
YOU HAVE TO EITHER HAVE
A LOT OF DONORS
OR YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A LOT OF APPLICANTS.
BECAUSE THE VALUE TO DONORS
IS YOU HAVE A VERY LARGE
BASE OF APPLICANTS,
AND THE VALUE
TO THE APPLICANTS IS
I'M GONNA GET MONEY
BESIDES FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
I DON'T BUY
THAT THE FRIENDS AND FAMILY
ARE GONNA PAY YOU 8%
TO DONATE THE MONEY
THEY COULD GIVE YOU DIRECTLY.
THE MARKET ACTUALLY SAYS
OTHERWISE IN SOME RESPECTS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
ALREADY USING CROWD FUNDING,
KNOWING THAT THERE'S A FEE
ALREADY ON TOP OF IT.
LOOK, YOU CAN'T CHARGE 8.5%.
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
OKAY.
I'M ALREADY INVESTED
IN HoneyFund AND PLUMFUND,
WHICH IS COMPETING WITH YOU
ON A BROADER SCALE.
DOESN'T MEAN
YOU WON'T BE SUCCESSFUL,
BUT IT MEANS I'M NOT
GOING TO INVEST IN
A COMPETITOR, OBVIOUSLY.
UNDERSTAND.
UNDERSTANDABLE.
SO, FOR THAT REASON, AND WITH
FULL RESPECT TO YOU GUYS,
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW,
I-I THINK THE IDEA HAS MERIT.
I THINK YOU GUYS SPENT A LOT
OF TIME THINKING ABOUT IT.
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE,
BUT I'M NOT CLEAR
HOW IT'S GONNA WORK.
I'M OUT.
LAST YEAR,
DAYMOND AND I INVESTED
IN THE SCHOLLY SCHOLARSHIP APP,
AND IT'S DOING REALLY WELL,
AND IT'S HELPING A LOT OF PEOPLE
GET CONNECTED WITH SCHOLARSHIPS.
THIS IS INTERESTING TO ME
BECAUSE IN SOME WAYS,
MAYBE WE COULD DO SOMETHING THAT
INTEGRATES THE TWO TOGETHER.
BUT YOU'RE JUST
BEGINNING STAGES.
LIKE, YOU HAVEN'T STARTED YET.
SO, FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, I'M SEEING FOUR
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES PITCHED.
I'M SEEING A PLATFORM
WHERE FRIENDS AND FAMILY
CAN GIVE TO A STUDENT'S
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE,
I'M SEEING A PLATFORM WHERE
STRANGERS CAN GIVE DIRECTLY
TO A STUDENT'S EDUCATION THE WAY
THAT A GoFundMe SITE GOES,
I'M SEEING A PLATFORM
FOR SETTING UP A SCHOLARSHIP
WHETHER AN INDIVIDUAL
OR FOUNDATION,
AND I'M SEEING A PLATFORM
WHERE A STUDENT CAN COME
AND FIND SCHOLARSHIPS THAT
THEY MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT WERE SET UP
BY AN INDIVIDUAL OR FOUNDATION.
ALL FOUR OF THOSE THINGS
ARE INTERESTING IDEAS.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN TACKLE
ALL FOUR OF THEM.
WITHOUT THAT KIND OF FOCUS,
I'M OUT.
I APOLOGIZE
FOR MAKING IT CONFUSING
BY NOT ADDRESSING IT
IN A MORE ORGANIZED MANNER,
BUT WE DO HAVE A PLAN.
THE PROBLEM IS
YOU CAME TOO EARLY.
IF YOU HAD ALREADY GONE
THROUGH THAT PROCESS
OF TURNING IT IN
FROM IDEA TO PLAN TO TANGIBLE,
I THINK YOU'D HAVE A SHOT,
BUT YOU'RE NOT THERE YET,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FEEDBACK,
AND WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE IT CONSTRUCTIVELY
AND IMPROVE OUR COMPANY.
THANK YOU.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-GOOD LUCK.
-THANK YOU.
♪♪
YOU CAN'T GET 8% FOR IT.
YOU HIT A CEILING AT 1%.
DOESN'T EVEN MATTER.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN TO THE POINT
WHERE IT'S EVEN RELEVANT.
THE BUSINESS MODEL IS --
IDEAS ARE CHEAP.
EXECUTION IS EVERYTHING.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT
DESIGNED TO MAINTAIN
DOMESTIC BLISS.
♪♪
GOOD DAY, SHARKS.
I AM KING
NICHOLAS GALEKOVIC...
-[ LAUGHS ]
-...PROTECTOR OF
THE FACE FOLLICLES.
AND I AM
QUEEN ALESSIA GALEKOVIC,
THE QUEEN OF THE KINGDOM.
AND TOGETHER, WE ARE
THE FOUNDERS OF BEARD KING.
WE'RE SEEKING $100,000
FOR 20% OF OUR ENTIRE KINGDOM.
SO, SHARKS,
AS LONG AS THERE'S BEEN MEN,
THERE'S BEEN FACIAL HAIR.
NOW, WHETHER THAT'S A BEARD,
MUSTACHE,
SIDEBURNS, OR ANY FACIAL HAIR
FOR THAT MATTER,
WE ALL HAVE ONE PROBLEM
IN COMMON.
THE FACT IS
GROOMING FACIAL HAIR
CAN BE A VERY MESSY
AND TIME-CONSUMING TASK.
SO, IMAGINE ALL THOSE
DISGUSTING, LITTLE HAIRS
ALL OVER YOUR SINK,
ALL OVER YOUR COUNTER,
ALL OVER YOUR SOAP,
ALL OVER YOUR TOOTHBRUSH,
EVENTUALLY CLOGGING YOUR SINK.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
GUESS WHO HAS TO CLEAN THAT UP?
ME.
-YOU SOUND EXACTLY LIKE MY WIFE.
-MM-HMM.
-THANK YOU.
-YES.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-EXACTLY.
NOW, LORD O'LEARY,
I KNOW YOU ONCE RELATED
TO THIS MADNESS
WITH YOUR ONCE-ALMIGHTY
BEARD.
Greiner: YOU HAD A BEARD?
O'Leary: OH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH!
Herjavec: THAT'S KEVIN?
NO WAY!
-THAT IS JUST
A BEAUTIFUL-LOOKING GUY.
-BEAUTIFUL.
[ LAUGHS ]
Alessia: AND, AS YOU KNOW,
WITH A GREAT BEARD
COMES
GREAT RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WE HAVE INVENTED
THE SOLUTION
FOR THIS VERY HAIRY
SITUATION.
LORDS AND LADIES,
PRESENTING THE WORLD'S FIRST
AND ONLY GROOMING TOOL
THAT ELIMINATES MANUAL CLEAN UP
AND ALLOWS FOR
AN EASY DISPOSAL.
THE BEARD BIB.
AND HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
PULL THE CONTENTS
OUT OF THE POUCH.
ATTACH THE NECK STRAPS.
STICK THE SUCTION CUPS
TO THE MIRROR,
THEN MOVE THE LEVERS DOWN.
BEGIN YOUR NORMAL
GROOMING REGIMEN.
OH, YOU'RE NOT SERIOUS!
ONCE COMPLETED,
FLIP THE SUCTION CUP UNITS UP
AND REMOVE.
LOWER OVER THE TRASH CAN
AND GENTLY SHAKE.
YEP.
SO...
-SERIOUSLY?
-[ LAUGHS ]
YES.
ARE YOU GUYS --
ARE YOU GUYS TOGETHER?
WE'RE MARRIED.
YES, WE'RE --
YES.
OKAY. AND SO THIS COMES UP.
THIS ISN'T A HYPOTHETICAL.
-THIS IS A REAL-LIFE SITUATION.
-THIS IS HOW WE CAME UP WITH IT.
THIS IS ACTUALLY
HOW WE CAME UP WITH IT.
HE WOULD ALWAYS
MAKE A MESS.
I'M A NEAT FREAK.
I WAS JUST SICK OF IT.
RIGHT.
SO, IT WAS
A CONSTANT BATTLE.
NICK, HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY OF THESE?
-YES.
-OH, OF COURSE.
TO DATE,
WE HAVE $140,000 IN SALES
JUST IN EIGHT MONTHS.
WOW. [ CLAPPING ] YEAH.
THANK YOU.
JUST LAST MONTH,
WE DID $80,000 IN SALES.
HOW? HOW DID YOU DO $80,000
IN A SINGLE MONTH?
OUR VIDEO WENT VIRAL
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE HAD
OVER 20 MILLION VIEWS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SERIOUSLY.
-OUR STRENGTH --
-THAT VIDEO YOU SHOWED US?
-YES, THAT VIDEO RIGHT THERE.
-YES, IT WAS HYSTERICAL.
SO, OUR BACKGROUND
AND OUR STRENGTH, FOR ME,
IS BRAND DEVELOPMENT.
SO, I CREATE
ALL THE CONTENT,
WE DID ALL THE BRANDING,
WE DID EVERYTHING OURSELVES.
AND SO, BY WORD OF MOUTH,
PEOPLE ARE CATCHING ONTO IT,
AND EVERY DAY, IT JUST
KEEPS GROWING AND GROWING.
-IT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU?
WHAT'S YOUR PROFIT?
WE JUST LAST MONTH
GOT OUR COSTS DOWN TO $7,
AND WE SELL IT FOR $29.
-WOW.
-GOOD MARGINS. GOOD MARGINS.
THE MARGINS ARE GOOD.
NOW --
THEY CAN GET EVEN BETTER
WITH YOUR GUYS' HELP.
THEY CAN GET --
WITH YOUR HELP, I THINK WE CAN
GET THE MARGINS TO ABOUT 85%.
CAN WE SEE THE PACKAGING?
OF COURSE.
OUR PACKAGING I LOVE,
SO YOU BETTER LOVE.
[ LAUGHS ]
WOW.
I'M SCARED
NOT TO LOVE IT.
IS THERE ANYTHING TO STOP
ANYBODY ELSE FROM MAKING THIS?
IT IS PATENT PENDING.
IT'S A PATENT
ON THE UTILITY --
AN APPARATUS ATTACHED
TO A MIRROR AROUND ONE'S NECK.
WELL, I GOT TO TELL YOU,
WHEN I FIRST SAW IT,
I THOUGHT IT WAS A JOKE,
BUT $140,000 IN SALES,
20 MILLION VIEWS,
I MEAN, YOU'RE --
YOU'RE DOING IT.
SO, WHY DO YOU NEED THE MONEY?
WE NEED THE MONEY
TO SCALE MANUFACTURING.
SEE, THAT'S OUR PROBLEM
RIGHT NOW.
WE LITERALLY CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND.
Cuban: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
YOU SOLD $140,000 --
-$80,000 LAST MONTH ALONE.
-YOUR MARGIN --
-RIGHT.
-CORRECT.
YOUR MARGINS ARE HUGE, RIGHT,
SO YOU'VE GOT 75% MARGINS.
Nicholas:
WELL, HERE'S THE THING.
THE FIRST SEVEN MONTHS,
OUR MARGINS WERE ONLY 40%.
OKAY.
SO, JUST RIGHT NOW,
WE GOT IT TO 75%.
SO, YOU NEED THE CASH FOR...
FOR -- FOR SCALING
MANUFACTURING.
FOR INVENTORY.
WHAT'S THE PROJECTION
FOR NEXT YEAR?
400K CONSERVATIVELY
ON THE GROWTH RATE WE'RE GOING.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA GO FROM
THE CURRENT SALES TO $400,000?
HAVE YOU TALKED TO RETAILERS?
HAVE YOU EVER TRIED TO APPROACH
A BIG BOX STORE?
SO, THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN APPROACHED
BY MANY WHOLESALE
AND DISTRIBUTORS,
AND WE WANTED TO STAY FOCUSED ON
OUR ONLINE DISTRIBUTION CHANNEL,
BUT, YOU KNOW, WITH YOUR HELP,
I THINK WE CAN GET THERE.
DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S A GOOD IDEA,
BECAUSE YOU'LL CUT
YOUR MARGINS IN HALF.
-RIGHT.
-CORRECT.
-YOU'LL OWN A LOT OF INVENTORY.
HERE'S MY CHALLENGE WITH IT.
YOU'RE DOING GREAT.
YOUR MARGINS ARE FANTASTIC.
YOU MAKE ENOUGH MARGIN
TO BOOTSTRAP THIS THING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU NEED
$100,000 TODAY FOR INVENTORY
BECAUSE YOU CAN DO IT
ON YOUR OWN.
AND THAT WAY,
YOU CAN PROVE THE SCALE.
I'M JUST -- I'M NOT SURE
HOW MY MONEY IS GONNA ACCELERATE
THIS BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
Cuban:
LOOK, WHEN I LOOK AT A COMPANY,
I TRY TO SEE
WHAT THE CORE COMPETENCY IS.
WHAT IS IT THAT THEY'RE GOOD AT,
AND HOW FAR CAN THAT TAKE THEM?
REALLY WHAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
AS YOUR CORE COMPETENCY
IS YOUR ABILITY
TO CREATE CONTENT.
IF YOU WERE TO COME IN HERE
AND SAID, "YOU KNOW WHAT,
THIS IS OUR FIRST PRODUCT.
WE ARE SO GOOD
AT CREATING CONTENT.
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE
OF A VIRAL VIDEO WE CREATED.
HERE'S THREE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE."
I'D BE INTERESTED.
WE DO. WE HAVE A BEARD --
BEARD BIB THAT'S DISPOSABLE.
WE WANT TO GAIN
AS MUCH SINK SHARE AS WE CAN
FROM THE MEN'S BATHROOM.
THAT'S OUR --
SO WE WANT TO DO
COMBS AND OILS.
Sacca: SINK SHARE?
WE HAVE COMBS --
YOU WANT TO GET SINK SHARE?
THAT'S OUR --
THAT'S OUR KEY --
THAT'S YOUR KEY METRIC?
SINK SHARE, YES.
SINK SHARE.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS
IF THIS WAS THE FIRST
OF MANY PRODUCTS
OF A WIDE SCOPE,
NOT JUST SINK SHARE,
BUT YOU ARE SHOWING ME
YOU ARE THE KING
OF CREATING VIRAL VIDEOS
TO SELL PRODUCTS,
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SELL ME.
I'M OUT.
IT'S AN INTERESTING IDEA,
BUT IT'S NOT A COMPANY.
IT'S A PRODUCT.
IT'S A BEARD DIAPER.
LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS.
WE HAVE A DISPOSABLE BIB,
WE HAVE BEARD OILS,
WE HAVE BEARD COMBS,
WE HAVE APPAREL.
NO, BUT I THINK ALL THAT STUFF,
I CAN GET IT IN 90,000 PLACES.
AND WE'VE HAD OTHER COMPANIES
UP HERE SELLING THE SAME THING.
CORRECT.
SURE, BUT HAVE YOU SEEN
A BEARD BIB BEFORE?
YOU HAVEN'T.
-NO, NO, BUT --
-IT'S THE FIRST IN ITS MARKET.
IT'S THE FIRST THING
THAT'S EVER BEEN --
-THE BIG THING --
THE BIB THING, I GET IT,
BUT IT'S A SINGLE PRODUCT.
HOW WOULD I GET MY MONEY BACK?
BY INVESTING IN US.
NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH.
YOU KNOW, LOOK,
MY BEARD DAYS ARE OVER.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THE PHOTO.
BROUGHT ME DOWN MEMORY LANE.
BUT I'M OUT.
I LOVE THE LOGO,
I LOVE THE POSITIONING.
I AM A COMPANY INVESTOR.
I BUILD COMPANIES.
I INVEST FOR THE LONG TERM.
THIS IS A PRODUCT.
I DON'T KNOW
HOW I'D BE THAT HELPFUL TO YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY, I'M OUT.
OKAY, GOT YOU.
I'M VERY SAD TO HEAR THAT,
I HAVE TO SAY.
AW.
WELL, THERE'S --
THERE'S ONE SHARK.
LORI.
-THERE'S ONE.
-BEARDLESS SHARK.
QUEEN LORI.
ONE BEARDLESS SHARK.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
MY CROWN WITH YOU.
WELL...
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME
IS THAT THE WOMEN ARE LEFT
WITH THE HAIR IN THE SINK.
IT'S A COMMON PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THERE'S REALLY
NO SOLUTION.
RIGHT.
AND WOMEN WOULD BUY
TO KEEP THEMSELVES HAPPY.
OVER 60% OF
OUR CUSTOMER BASE IS WOMEN.
WOMEN THAT HAVE A BOYFRIEND,
A HUSBAND, A SON.
I COULD SEE IT
MAKING WOMEN HAPPY.
BUT I'M NOT QUITE SURE
HOW WELL THIS WILL DO --
BEFORE YOU GO OUT, COULD
YOU MAKE US AN OFFER THEN?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT DO YOU THINK --
WHAT -- WHAT --
IT WOULD -- WHAT WOULD YOU THINK
ON THE EQUITY SIDE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD,
YOU KNOW, BE WORTH TO YOU
TO TAKE --
TO TAKE THAT JUMP WITH US?
♪♪
All:
LORI! LORI! LORI! LORI! LORI!
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
LORI IS NICHOLAS AND ALESSIA'S
LAST CHANCE
FOR A DEAL FOR THEIR
BEARD-TRIMMING BIB, BEARD KING.
-LORI! LORI! LORI!
-I -- [ CHUCKLES ]
-LORI! LORI!
-BEARD QUEEN!
-COME ON.
-YOU GOT TO DO IT, LORI.
♪♪
OH, MY GOSH.
WE HAVE DE-RISKED YOU
BY JUST PROVING A MARKET.
WE'VE ALREADY --
WE HAVE PROVED THE MARKET.
THERE'S GROWING SALES
EVERY MONTH.
YOU KNOW, AS --
$80,000 IN ONE MONTH.
THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT IT ISN'T.
AND WE'RE STILL ON TRACK
FOR THAT THIS MONTH,
SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M SAYING TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
BECAUSE I SEE THIS
AS SO, SO, SO RISKY...
♪♪
...I WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
51% OF THE COMPANY.
[ GROANS ]
Herjavec: WHOA.
BOO-YAH.
OKAY.
WOW.
O'Leary: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
51%?
LORI IS OFFERING --
-I WAS SERIOUS,
BECAUSE YOU WOULD --
-THAT'S YOUR COUNTER.
-GET YOUR $100,000.
-WELL, LISTEN. YOU SAID --
THAT IS A STEEP OFFER,
AND I KNOW IT.
-CORRECT.
-BUT I WAS GOING OUT.
-WELL, AND THEY COUNTERED.
SO, YOU SAID
WHAT WOULD I DO.
I DON'T WANT TO --
DON'T YOU SEE THIS DOING
VERY WELL ON YOUR QVC?
I MEAN, IT'S A DIRECT --
IT IS DIRECT TO CONSUMER.
AS SOON AS YOU SEE IT,
IT TRIGGERS AN EMOTION.
IT TRIGGERS --
IT TRIGGERS SOMETHING
IN EVERYBODY BECAUSE --
I THOUGHT IT WAS A VERY,
VERY CLEVER VIDEO.
REALLY,
IT MADE EVERYBODY LAUGH.
EVERYBODY COULD RELATE TO IT.
I MEAN, I GET IT.
WELL, WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP
CONTROL OF THE COMPANY.
WE WOULD CONSIDER MAX...
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
[ MUMBLES ]
HMM?
WE WOULD DO 45% WITH YOU
IF YOU --
WE WOULD DO 45%.
IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO GO THERE.
MAX.
YOU HAVE TO COUNT THE FACT
THAT WE ARE SO GREAT
AT OUR MARKETING...
LORI. LORI.
...AND BRANDING
AND SHARING,
DOING VIRAL CONTENT.
LORI. LORI.
I MEAN, THAT'S HUGE.
WE'VE DONE THIS FROM NOTHING.
LORI,
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
WE WORK SO HARD.
WE DO.
THIS IS ALL WE DO.
WILL YOU THROW IN THE SHIRT?
WILL YOU THROW IN
THE BEARD KING SHIRT FOR HER?
YES,
I'LL THROW IN THE SHIRT
AND SOMETHING ELSE
THAT YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW.
-WHAT?
-WHAT? MAYBE WE WANT BACK IN.
-[ Laughing ] OH, MY GOD.
-MAYBE. MAYBE YOU DO.
THIS COULD CHANGE EVERYTHING.
THIS COULD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban:
LORI, YOU GOT TO DO IT!
YOU GOT TO DO IT!
LORI!
OH!
I'M READY TO CROWN YOU.
DONE.
[ ALL CHEERING ]
STANDING OVATION
FOR LORI.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-YAY.
Sacca:
WE GOT TO STAND. WE'RE IN
THE PRESENCE OF ROYALTY.
Cuban: YEAH! WOW.
THANK YOU, LORI.
YOU'RE OUR NEW QUEEN.
[ VOCALIZING
"HAIL TO THE CHIEF" ]
O'Leary:
OH, MY GOODNESS.
THANK YOU.
OH, MY GOD.
-ALL RIGHT.
-LORI! LORI!
-OH, MY NEW "SHARK TANK" OUTFIT.
-THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-YOU'RE GREAT.
-THANK YOU, GUYS.
-BYE.
-OH, MY GOSH.
YOU -- YOU ARE GONNA BE A HERO
TO WOMEN EVERYWHERE.
OH, MY GOD.
Nicholas:
LITTLE HIGHER THAN WE WANTED.
BUT --
IT WAS, YEAH.
SHE'S --
SHE'S THE PERFECT SHARK.